we chose the boycott we feel that it's a
slap in the face last week Will Smith
announced he will join his wife Jada
Pinkett Smith in boycotting the 2016
Oscars over the lack of diversity in the
nominations but it's not the first time
the actor has pushed back against an
award show explaining to ET in 1989 why
he and musical partner DJ Jazzy Jeff
decided to boycott music's biggest night
after the Academy chose to not air the
rap category on TV we boycotted the 1989
Grammy Show we don't have a problem with
the Grammy as an award or the Grammy as
an institution we just had a problem
with the 1989 design of the award show
we feel that our music was important
enough and is important enough to have
been on this show the duo won their
first Grammy ever that year for their
hit parents just don't understand
despite being honored their real goal
was standing up for their genre I think
it was just um lack of knowledge the
ignorance on the part of nares they
don't know anything about rap music and
our boycott was to open their eyes to
rap music so next year some rap group
will be able to perform on the Grammys
and the award will be televised because
the music isn't large enough and
important enough to be on that show
seems like the Grammys listened the
following year 1990 they began
televising the rap category this is a
milestone in our career and it's a
milestone in
the history of rap